- Alright, Annika.
Annika, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- Menlo park.
- Okay and tell me about your family,
you had both your parents as a kid?
- Yes, I did.
My dad was a homicide detective and my mom
she did like computer
stuff, secretarial stuff.
- [Interviewer] Good childhood?
Oh yeah very good childhood.
- [Interviewer] No traumatic craziness?
- Yeah no abuse, nothing from my family.
I mean, I had some traumatic
incidents as a teenager,
but as far as growing
up the police department
or my babysitters and I
went on patrol all the time
and it was lots of fun and
yeah it was a good childhood,
and my parents are still together.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- And, yeah.
- [Interviewer] So after
you lived with your parents,
where did you go from there?
- I graduated high school two years early.
So I went--
- [Interviewer] So you're a good student?
- Yeah, yeah, so I went right to college.
Then I took a hiatus for like seven years
before graduate school.
- [Interviewer] Where do you go to school?
- Currently I'm a law school
dropout from Stanford.
- [Interviewer] Stanford?
- Yep.
- [Interviewer] Interesting.
- Yeah, yep.
- [Interviewer] So now you're
living in the Tenderloin?
- I am, I am now living in the Tenderloin.
Lots of ups and downs
have brought me here.
- [Interviewer] What
kind of stuff happened
that got you on the street here?
- Well the whole getting kicked yeah,
I got arrested for 0.004
grams over an ounce
of weed when it was still a felony.
And so becoming a felon limited
my chances of employment
I lost my scholarship, everything.
So um,
yeah I got back on heroin
which I've had a love affair
with for 23 years now.
So uh, yeah.
Getting into that hardcore
after getting released
from school is kind of what brought me
on the downward spiral here.
Although I was a functional addict
but then I started smoking
crack, unfortunately,
and that really brought me
here before I was, you know,
at least functional, you know,
and been off opiates
at all since I was 18.
- [Interviewer] So what
is your drug today?
- Fentanyl.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- Yeah.
Yep.
But I don't shoot up anymore.
So after like 21 years of shooting up
I haven't touched a needle
in like over a year now
so I just smoke it and yeah
the efficacy is definitely
a little bit better
than the heroin you get
out here on the West coast.
- [Interviewer] So you're
living today, where in a tent?
- No, I actually got
lucky and the hot team
found me just sitting on golden gate
and now I live in a swanky
hotel in union square.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- [Interviewer] Thanks to them?
- Thanks to asthma.
I'm high-risk in the
era of the Corona virus.
- [Interviewer] So
that's temporary perhaps?
- Uh six months but it'll give me a chance
to save up with this
unemployment thing, so.
- [Interviewer] what
are you doing for money
or what were you doing for money before?
- I was stealing stuff and
selling the merchandise.
- [Interviewer] Boosting?
- Yeah, yup.
High-end wine usually.
- [Interviewer] I mean what do
you think got you from having
a scholarship to Stanford,
to drug addicted, homeless?
- Well, I mean, I've, I've
been on heroin since I was 16
so I managed to make it
through all the college
and stuff while on opiates,
methadone for a lot of that.
- [Interviewer] And you
got through high school
two years early as an addict?
- Yeah no I wasn't quite
an addict when I graduated
high school I was just getting into it
right after but a series of
suicides of my best friends
and high school sweetheart
kind of threw me
over the edge and just
into full addiction.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- And yeah.
- [Interviewer] What does
your family think of you?
- I'm the black sheep completely.
My uncle on my mom's
side died of an OD and
yeah my mom just still kind of blames me
for that because during my
grandma's funeral afterwards
he asked if I could hook
him up with heroin and I did
but that's not what he died from.
He died several years later but
he was the only one in my family that
actually understood me
being a junkie and stuff.
- [Interviewer] Are there
moments in your life
where you look at your situation
and say, what the hell?
- Everyday, everyday.
- [Interviewer] I mean
you're a great example
because it's so many of the commenters,
the viewers on my channel
will make comments like that
like making these oh you just got to go
to rehab and get your act together
and get a job and get back
to your kids or do whatever.
Here's clearly somebody
who's probably brighter
than everybody where at
this, watching this video.
- Yeah, you know my dad insists
that that's all I need is a program.
And it's just, I, I know myself
and that is not what I need at all.
Like I can function with stability
but without stability and you know support
then that's where I--
- [Interviewer] So perhaps this housing
that you now have because
of coronavirus might--
- Exactly.
- [Interviewer] You could
use it as a spring board--
- And I'm going to be
getting like over 600 a week
from unemployment.
So I can actually get my shit together.
Finally.
- [Interviewer] So you
have hope of something?
- Definitely, definitely.
I'm an artist now.
I've been an artist my whole life.
That's always been my like fallback thing.
- [Interviewer] That
might be more satisfying
than law school for you.
- It definitely has been,
it's definitely more relaxing.
I mean, I was so idealistic
my first year of school,
but I've become so disillusioned.
- [Interviewer] So drug addiction
and coronavirus might be
two of the best things
that ever happened to you.
- You know, maybe, maybe.
I find my mom always wanted me
to just do my artwork instead
of the law, but, you
know, I think she's right.
I think she's finally right.
So I finally agree with
something she's saying.
- [Interviewer] So what, you know,
as somebody who's clearly
very very intelligent,
what do you think people
that are not addicts that
that watch some of my videos
and watch stories like yours?
What do you think they don't
understand about addiction?
- That it's not something that
one can just walk away from?
You know, it becomes a part of somebody.
And I mean, yeah, it's
a huge part of my life.
I might not be a positive
thing in some people's minds
but it is, you know, definitely
a huge part of my life.
And I can't negate that at all.
And those kinds of people need to realize
that it takes more than just, you know,
programs and whatever else the, the media,
and the politicians say
is the cure for addiction.
It's, there's a lot of aspects to it.
And I don't even know them all.
I don't know what would cure me, but I,
I functioned perfectly fine
on minimal amounts of opiates.
And I don't think I could
ever completely be off of them
nor would I really want to be.
I haven't been sober sober,
off of everything for over 20 years.
- [Interviewer] Have you OD'd before?
- [Annika] Once years
and years and years ago.
- [Interviewer] And fentanyl
is an easy one to do that with, yeah?
- [ Annika] I have never OD'd on fentanyl.
I'm glad I don't shoot it because yeah
the probability of that goes way up.
But that's another thing that
my parents don't understand
about the whole heroin thing.
I mean this whole fentanyl
crisis is going on
and I'm, you know, a part of that.
But if I wasn't doing all the heroin
my tolerance would be so low
that I would probably be dead
by now from doing the fent.
And so they don't really realize that
because of having a high
tolerance of opiates
I'm probably still alive because of that.
They don't get it at all.
They just think it's illegal, so it's bad.
Although ironically
my mom is growing weed
and smokes it constantly.
Now that my dad retired and it's legal.
- [Interviewer] And
how old are you Annika?
- 38.
- [Interviewer] 38, and do you have kids?
- I do not, I have cats.
- [Interviewer] So it's foreseeable
that you can get your life
together or somewhat together?
- Yeah I believe I will.
I believe I will.
This is phase right now of my existence
- [Interviewer] Even
though you've been addicted
for a long time.
But do you envision a day
one day when you're not
addicted to not using at all?
- No I don't think I
will ever not use opiates
whether it be methadone
or fentanyl or heroin,
I or some other, you
know, future invention.
I don't know, but I just,
I don't know myself, not on opiates.
- [Interviewer] What advice
would you give to a young girl
who's watching this video saying yeah
this is something that I'm interested in.
- I would tell them, you know,
I honestly don't even know, like,
I'm not going to tell anybody to not do it
but just know your limits
and, and don't push them,
like I have, I mean,
that's been my thing all the time.
It's just pushing the
limits and just seeing
you know how much more I could get.
And yeah, it doesn't always
lead to the best of places.
- [Interviewer] It's almost
like the way you're wired
is the way you're wired.
- Right.
- [Interviewer] Telling somebody
to not be wired the way they are is--
- Exactly I have an addictive personality.
If it wasn't opiates, it'd be alcohol,
which it was at one point
and I thankfully stopped
drinking four years ago.
So yeah, that,
that was way worse in
my opinion, the alcohol.
- [Interviewer] You don't
look like an addict.
- [Annika] Well, thank you.
I appreciate that very much
because sometimes I feel
like I'm profiled when I'm going boosting.
- [[Interviewer] You
don't look like somebody
that's using drugs on the street.
- Well, thank you.
Thank you.
I do try.
- [Interviewer] Alright Annika,
thank you so much for talking with me
- Absolutely.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with
your new, your new housing.
It sounds great.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- [Annika] Well that was fun.